so I want you to think about this I want
you to think about the greatest
basketball player of all time let's call
him Michael Jordan right he chooses
somebody to be his trainer this iconic
player chooses one person to train him
for 15 years and you have a chance to
sit down with them and talk to him
imagine that person who is that person
that MJ pigs it's my friend here Tim
Grover who's here with us today
after how are you I am I'm good man I've
been looking forward to this like you
don't know I just had good lunch
together
we had a great lunch yes we did and I
got this ring on right now which goes
perfect with the outfit it's a 1990 1991
the first one first close championship
ring versus Jack ship I kind of like
wearing that it's it's it's it's you can
wear it you don't wear it until this
interview is over
Solomon let me take us what he's
promised us here's a you have promised
me that in today's interview you gonna
cover stuff you've never covered before
in any other interview absolutely never
never I'm looking stuff that I'm saying
today in this interview okay from the
questions that you're gonna ask me the
answers I have never said before so
let's get right into him and I'm like a
12 year old right now Cigna asking all
these questions to get into it okay so
look before we get into the whole
mindset and relentless and in the cooler
you know the closer to cleaner all these
other things how did this how did this
whole thing come about so you know who
was Tim Grover in high school post how
did that relationship with MJ get so why
don't we start off there first well I
actually played college basketball
myself I mean I played at a University
of illinois-chicago small Division one
school mid mid major but in order for me
just to play at that level you know I
had to work extremely hard but I knew I
wasn't gonna go pro all right you know
yet realize hey it's not gonna happen I
tell you there's great story about it I
was actually I was either a sophomore
junior and I this point guard came into
the gym from a high school and I played
him in a one-on-one or he was a junior
in high school and I was either
sophomore junior in college he kicked my
ass really kick mice I'm talking about
three years younger than I am in high
school you know hunger den yeah yo girl
I'm talking I was a I was a I was in
college he was a high school he was a
junior in high school I was a junior in
college you know who it was Tim Hardaway
Tim Hardaway Miami hits him hard with
Golden State yeah okay wipe the floor
with Wow I knew right then and then I
said what I knew he was going pro yeah
and second I said I have no chance no
chance okay but I wanted to be involved
in sports and I still wanted to be
involved in sports
ideally basketball so I said you know
what if I can't do it all right let me
figure out a way let me educate myself
so I can help others stay injury-free
become better athletes make better
decisions become the top of their game
so I started to study kinesiology and
exercise physiology and that's what led
me towards working with the greatest
wellyou're is this oh my goodness we're
talking about lates 79 to 84 85 and that
was your solenoid that's when you're
studying kinesiology both okay
yeah I'm a couple months older than you
maybe you'll be listening I'm doing a
math you don't look you're a dope I'm
doing the math right yeah okay so when
did when did you get to the point where
you started saying i'ma go and get some
of these NBA players and was your target
like did you put target right off the
bat I'm going straight to enjoy what you
know what when I started when I started
starting everyone says aw you're gonna
be a gym teacher I said no I saw my work
with professional athletes I knew what I
wanted to do is I'm gonna work with I'm
going to work with professional athletes
so that was my that was the goal I set
in my mind and I just said hey that
that's gonna take a place in my head
that's the only thing that I want to do
and I got to figure out a way to I got
to figure out a way to get there so I
started and learned my craft better than
anybody else did I start with the
professional athletes knowing after I
graduated I went to work in a local
health club really I knew how I knew
everything from a book standpoint but
still you got to know how to apply it
okay so I you know worked with anybody I
could any these are not pro these aren't
pros I'm talking about housewives I'm
talking about individuals that just want
to get in just want to get in shape
people that have had injuries from
different sports kids anybody just kind
of developing programs putting
implementing what I've learned and
actually being able to apply it mm-hmm
and once I started to look at that craft
I said okay now I'm starting to figure
out how to actually apply this stuff and
how to use it and put the formulas
together and put the workouts together
and do all these different things I mean
stuff that they're doing now from a
workout standpoint who was doing 30
years ago I knew too you know I mean
some of the stuff is you are it's
different I stay on top of it right all
right I got to continue to learn you
know continue to be better myself so I
can better my athletes better my craft
but it it's a different it's just a
different way of doing the same a
different way of doing the same thing
right now there's a lot more resources a
lot more education a lot more testing
available back then you kind of had to
just figure it out and I think that was
going YouTube there was none of this
online stuff to go to in real life right
yeah I also think now is the ability
that you have all this stuff now people
just can't figure it out that's one of
the thing that's taken away from
individuals now okay because they have
all this vast information and they're
always there's so much information
available there's so much help out there
that everyone's always looking for
somebody else to figure out stuff that
you should be able to figure out your
ten how do you how do you pick and
choose who to listen to
you know I pick and choose who I want to
listen to somebody that resonates with
me okay and I'll tell you this is this
is this is a little different okay you
know why would I how I choose a client
and how who I listen to that person has
to be as [ __ ] up as I okay seriously
okay so we're in a good position yeah
that person if when I choose a client
okay they have to be as messed up with
most MSW I'm sorry Z we ship all
sidewise yeah
I'm talking about addicted everything to
being great they have to do they gotta
want it okay they gotta want it okay I
know I'm crazy how do you figure it out
when you see them you know what you can
figure it out in ten minutes just by
talking to a while okay you ask the
right questions you talk to the
individual and then you see if they back
it up because anybody can talk the story
right you know what's the cheapest thing
in the world
talk the price has never gone up it's
never gonna go up but when you actually
tell somebody to back it up and you say
now I want you to do this this and this
that because now it becomes a different
point so when you choosing someone when
you choose somebody to listen to and you
choose somebody to learn from and you
choose a business partner you choose a
client they gotta be as crazy and they
gotta be as [ __ ] up as you that's how
you get success that's how you know
you're gonna be able to push that
individual that's how you know that
relationship is gonna last you know
people talk about in business or think
oh you gotta find a balance you got to
find that person you know if you're one
way you got to find a person that's the
other way know there's [ __ ] that's
pulling you away from how you want to do
things and how if you're intense the
next person I want is to be as super
intense super intense now those people
around you they got to be smarter than
you are right but you don't want to
surround yourself with people that if
you're the smartest person in the room
you need to get more people in the room
sure okay you should not walk into a
room and ever be the smartest person in
there but the people around you have to
be much smarter or at least in certain
things you may have an expertise in one
thing but that other individual better
have an expertise that's beyond yours in
something and something else like but
from the my standpoint you know MJ was
just as [ __ ] up as I was Co be just as
[ __ ] up as I was from a--from being
the best
okay I wanted to be the best at what I
do they wanted to be the best at what
they do
all right it was an attraction it's an
attract and those are the people that
allow you to push them and allow them to
they understand they want to get they
want to get better you know they don't
need to be motivated okay they're like
you tell them hey the more interesting
they're not they're not hiring
- come motivate me nobody wanted as bad
as you so what the best-of-the-best
already wanted more than anybody else
there's a reason they're the best you
know we we talked about this earlier at
lunch they're the ones that are show up
to practice early okay they're the ones
taking the extra shots the other ones
doing the wind sprints at the end
they're the ones you know getting
treatment taking care of the body
they're showing up they're showing up on
off days you're saying you're sending
the guys home you're saying you gotta go
gotta go home you got a little eat you
gotta you gotta tell them to leave you
don't have to tell them to show up got
tell them to leave that that that that's
enough you know you have people in your
office you look at it you know how many
employees do you have now
we got 40 218 4200 agents okay
I had 4200 agents okay if you put them
all in all in the room okay and you were
able to put them all in one shop
together all right and say your hours
were 9:00 to 5:00 okay
you'd have 4200 people in here from
night from 9:00 to 5:00 o'clock from
5:00 o'clock after 5:00 o'clock may have
500 after 7 o'clock you may have 200
after nine o'clock you may have five and
then guess what at the end of the day
there's gonna be one light left on maybe
to yours and somebody else's that person
is as [ __ ] up as you are but you can
count on that you can count on that
individual tell me first time with
energy so what happened there so you had
how did you connect with mg how did you
get to the point where MJ this is how it
really started so I sent letters out to
everybody in the Chicago Bulls
organization all the players and I'd
have to be a historian a basketball to
really know this and you may not even
know this because of your age there was
a player on the team named Brad Sellars
little skinny kids 6-11 out of Ohio
State so I was like okay kids got some
talent they don't need some help
physically maybe I could target him so I
sent letters to all the Bulls players
except Michael except Mike why'd you
why'd you do that you know I'm a young
kid he doesn't need any help you know
he's a Bay he's gonna be great he's
gonna be all that I get one phone call
back guess who was from
Michael there you go the
best-of-the-best
wanted to get even better the guy who
didn't get the letter the guy who didn't
get the letter when and looked into the
wedding got it out of somebody else's
life out of somebody else's Locker and
told the athletic trainer and a team
doctor at the time talk to this guy okay
talk to him so I met with the athletic
trainer was Mark file at the time and
that was a team doctor who was dr. John
Heffron at the time long interview
process they asked me all the questions
you know from a medical standpoint from
a training standpoint to know if I knew
what I was talking about and I had to do
the process again that I had to do the
process again then I get a phone call
and they said hey Michael wants to meet
you after practice that you still
haven't met Michael I still have not met
my still not met Michael okay so this is
in December of 1989 this is when Pittman
first comes Pittman cam 88 was a
December grant comedian December
December I think Pippin and grant came
the same year if I remember maybe
because there's the party together yeah
that's right
so in 89 in December I go to they tell
me Michael wants to meet you have to
practice at his house so I go to his
house all right I pull up over there and
I looked down on my shoes I'm wearing
converse
you know everybody knows my cousin here
Jordan it's it's the it's the iconic
Jumpman logo I'm like man I can't go in
this house we're in Converse okay now
remember this is December in Chicago it
gets kind of cold one be fine so I take
off the shoes I got holes in my socks oh
my oh I said I can't have this guy so I
take off my socks too I knock on the
door he opens up the door and the first
thing he looks down he goes I said you
know Michael hey real clean house you
know I wanted to take off my shoes and
socks I'm gonna leave him I'm gonna
leave him out here he said okay so I
come in he says introduce myself to him
telling my background tell him what I
what I've started and so forth and he
goes all right how can you help me and I
go through all the process of how he's
had these nagging injuries and why he's
had these things and what we can do to
alleviate these things to help him you
know feel better and be allowed to
perform at a higher level and he just
goes he goes this is
sounds too good I said no I said this is
actually I can lay this out pretty much
I said I can tell you how you're gonna
feel in 24 hours are you gonna feel in
48 72 this is exactly what's what's
gonna what's gonna happen all right and
oh you guys the same age are you a you
were pretty close I am going I think I
always lost Connor I'm either 52 or 54
baby okay and Michael's 62 so he's two
years older than I so your story younger
than him I'm still he is listening to
you yes okay all right age has got not
age has got nothing to do with know some
stats a while you know this person is
older than me they're not gonna listen
to me
no age has got nothing to do with much
okay I don't come across as an expert at
what he does I come in at an expert and
what I do okay and there's a lot of
individuals out there that try to come
in and they try to become experts and
every at everything all of a sudden you
know you have trainers and so forth that
if they're working with a baseball
player they're all sudden teaching them
how to how to swing a bat or I don't
know do what you do do what you do so
when I did when I got with mg I did I
did what I say this is this is what I do
now do I know about the game of
basketball yes I do know about the game
as much as he does
no but that's where my learning process
comes in he's gonna learn from me I'm
gonna learn from him he says let's try
this out so I give you 30 days 30 days
turned into 15 years 15 years these days
it was 15 50 and that's you know and
that's key there because a lot of
individuals now okay
especially in this generation not only
from a training standpoint but from a
knowledge standpoint they're jumping
from one thing to another you know
they're using this trainer this week
they're using another trainer next week
you know they're using this person as a
mentor on YouTube then they're using
this person over here okay and they're
getting all this conflicting information
okay you got a you got a master what
you're going to master okay you have to
fit you have to figure out too many
people are jumping from place to place
the place Michael Kobe all these
individuals they mastered
one aspect of the game when they
mastered that aspect of the game then
they moved to another aspect of the game
you know how many individuals you have a
hundred and thousands people following
you okay you put content out on a
regular basis and what do people always
ask they want more content they want
more content they can't remember what
the [ __ ] you said two days ago right
okay and they're already onto the next
lesson you got a master that stuff
that's just a message on the line width
I mean Tim I 100% aligned with that
message so he stays with you for 50
keepers you for 50 15 I did basketball I
did the retirement I did baseball I did
back to basketball of it I did all of it
so he had a deal with you he said what
he said he wanted you he hired you but
there was one well you couldn't train
anybody it was a story it was the thing
is MJ used to say goes man I don't pay
you to train me I pay you not to train
anybody else okay now for the first
three years I was with him he didn't
allow me to train anybody else okay
three years three years she said you
can't work that's what 89 90 91 yeah so
he can't work with you can't work with
anybody you can't work with anybody else
then after that during the offseason
when it when it wasn't our time he
allowed me to pick up some other pick up
some of them did you pick up anybody
from the Pistons were you with anyone
from the Pistons some of his main guy I
mean most of the guys I picked up were
local Chicago guys I mean he brought
Scottie on a board he bought Ron Harper
on a board sure I trained the local guys
from Chicago like Nick Anderson the big
Nick Anderson played he played Orlando
he played an Orlando Kendall Gill you
know these were all Illinois guys were
all Chicago guys they were Chicago or
Chicago was home so I was working with
all those individuals but the deal I had
with those guys I said listen when the
boss calls I've only had one boss he's
only person I've ever called boss he
says when he calls I gotta go if we long
you guys have that under you guys have
that understanding we're good
and I told him I said you guys would not
be working out with me if it wasn't for
him that's just amazing so let me ask
this look because I want to set the tone
first so from there
you know we can go into some of the
other items in the book relentless you
talk about the three levels right yeah
we talked about the cooler the closer to
cleaner before I cover the 13 points
here if you had to break in us simply
what would the difference between the
three be no less a cooler is an
individual that's good at what they do
right you give them a job to do
they get the job done the results are
what you expect there's nothing great
yeah it's nothing that it's nothing
exceptional it's adequate you have a
closer a closer individual that gives
you those exceptional results as long as
you give them a game plan and as long as
too many variables aren't from I've
thrown at them okay then you have the
cleaner the cleaner is gonna get you
that end result over and over again and
this is key elevate everybody around him
he's gonna raise he or she is gonna
raise their game and he's gonna deliver
that result numerous times I don't want
to not just one no matter what's thrown
at them no matter what variable is
thrown at them they have the ability to
focus no matter what variable is thrown
out there no matter what variable okay
and you know when we talk about sports
okay you see all these individuals
they've got to deal with injuries they
got off court they got off court you
know they're human beings just like
everybody else but the cleaner never
brings that stuff to work never brings
it to work once they step on that
football field that baseball diamond the
soccer field the basketball court no one
knows it doesn't matter it doesn't
matter you know you have individuals
hire you when you see somebody's
productivity at work fluctuate up and
down right it usually has nothing to do
with what's going on at work it's
usually what's going on in that personal
motto what an incredible item to cover
okay and they bring it to work yeah
cleaners don't bring their personal [ __ ]
to work yeah they don't what Michael has
is it can you learn that or is that
something that you either all of this
can be learn all 13 of them all of this
can be
learn okay and we talked about this in a
relentless system how you're not born
with this this is something that can be
learned but what happens is when you
everyone's gonna hit adversity yep okay
everyone's gonna hit adversity it's how
you deal with that adversity and the key
word is you not letting somebody else
deal with a niversity you have to deal
with an adversity and how you deal with
it are you gonna fight through it or are
you gonna curl up and just roll over in
the corner it's gonna pretty much
determine how the rest of your
development from a mental standpoint is
going to carry you you know people talk
about this people talk about this all
the time you know losing builds
character okay well how much [ __ ]
character do you need seriously all
right you don't want to keep losing and
losing hey listen I'd rather have a
person win who has a little bit of who
has a little bit of character yeah okay
who's a little nuts and a person that
loses all the time and he's got he's got
a great character at some point you got
to start you got to start winning you
can't always look for other people to
help you other people got their own
problems they got their own [ __ ] they
got to deal with they're trying to
achieve their own goals their will they
are willing to assist but after a while
okay if you constantly looking for a
system constantly looking for help it's
it's on you your failure and your
success is on you and isn't that great
because you have control if you think
about it that way I mean if it's
external you can't control external if
it's internal you can control all the
inter so Tim how about I cover some of
these thirteen of our cleaners think and
then sure so we can we can kind of dress
this so here's what you got cleaners you
keep pushing yourself harder when
everybody else has had enough one you
get into the zone you shut out
everything else you control the
uncontrollable that's all about clarity
it's clear all about clarity okay
the zone is about clarity that's all it
is it's about the individuals that can
block everything out that can not only
see so and see okay so you don't want
you hear this about how many times have
you watched sports and they said the per
since thinking too much stop thinking
stop thinking just go out just go out
and play well what happens when you tell
an individual to stop thinking what's
the first thing they do they start
thinking exactly do you know how many
hours and years of preparation go into
not being able to not to think about
something okay it takes years and years
and years of doing the same [ __ ]
thing over and over and over again okay
twice on how not to not to think to be
able to take a to take a reaction yeah
and turn it into a reflex that's what
the greatest can do most people react to
things
okay the greatest it's it's an instinct
it's it's impulsive its innate it
becomes it becomes a reflex you know we
talked about this listen trust your
instincts that's what closers do you
know what cleaners do their instincts
trust them I got this I'll give you a
great example about that it will pick up
the other thing all right Doug Collins
coach of the Bulls yep there's drawn up
this play okay last second play he's
drawn it's the Cleveland play the one he
beat off you look you know right yeah so
he's drawing up all he's drawing up this
play all this other stuff he's over he
raises it Michaels turns around said hey
give me the ball get the [ __ ] out the
way in the timeout yeah after the time
made you know before I'm done just give
me the ball get the [ __ ] out the way
okay that's that's the don't think okay
that's the point where hey listen my
instincts trust me
give me the ball just get the hell out
the way I'm winning this game hmm I'm
winning this game
but that game-winning shot wasn't made
there it was made many years before in
the hill in the dark Jim by himself with
somebody rebounding the ball whether it
was me or somebody else shooting that
same shot over and over and over and
over again say no if I get to this spot
I don't care if there's ten hands in
front of me if I get to this spot the
shots going it because I've done it over
and
over again and we see it over and over
again on commercials now everywhere
that's cleared yeah
clarity now obviously he had it at the
highest level okay so the third one we
got you know exactly who you are you
know exactly who you are okay the key to
with the key that one your obligation to
yourself okay has to be greater than
anybody else's obligation to you what
does that mean okay you get so many
people that want [ __ ] for you more than
you want it for yourself okay your
obligation to yourself to be the best to
achieve the highest level has to be
greater the pressure you put on yourself
has to exceed anybody else's pressure
that puts on you outside that's what
they're that's why Tom Brady is able to
come from was a twenty eight whatever
where there's twenty eight three
whatever it was okay because the
pressure he put on himself is way
greater than what anybody else could
able to do that's why when he doesn't
have his top receivers okay you talk
about clarity and being able to put
pressure on yourself and his obligation
is greater than himself then it is what
anybody else could put on him okay why
he can take average receivers and make
him superstars because he elevates their
game he makes the game simple for them
you know what he says this is what I
want you to do okay you're gonna run ten
yards you're gonna break left okay I'm
gonna throw you the ball it's gonna hit
you in these two fingers right here all
you got to do is catch the ball all you
got to do you don't have to do anything
else okay when you turn and you put your
hands up the balls gonna hit you right
here
catch the ball okay and if you don't
catch the ball guess what he holds you
accountable he holds you accountable you
look at one of the plays last year here
was with Julian Edelman you dropped the
pass you told Julian Julian you gotta
catch a [ __ ] ball yeah I catch a
[ __ ] ball and what element said he
goes you know you're absolutely right I
can't make it any easier for you
I'm telling you where I'm gonna throw it
where it's gonna hit you in the fingers
okay yeah catch em all vacation as high
as well brown people yes people that
people say if you want to be happy have
no expectations of other people you ever
heard that quote so if you want to be
happy have no expectations of other
people
knew that in a team environment where
people are trying to win and do
something that's never been done before
yeah I mean well what it is it's listen
the expectations of yours are a lot
higher than everybody else's you can't
come down to theirs so the key when we
talked about cleaners as yours is gonna
be high the hardest thing to do is to
elevate everybody else around you
because if people get around say hey
listen if I can do it why can't they
okay everybody can't do it okay I love
this one you know people talk about this
we're all born with greatness we're not
[ __ ] for with greatness you earn
greatness okay that's a [ __ ] line to
sell [ __ ] [ __ ] to talk about we're
all born with greatness
okay that's the Ross stuff about giving
people hugs and five high fives and all
that other that's a [ __ ] high okay I
tell people you know yeah you know what
parent you know hey what do you got to
do to get to paradise you got a fight
like [ __ ] hell to get the [ __ ]
paradise people don't know how to fight
anymore they don't know how to fight
Paradise starts in hell and people quit
because they don't know what to deal
with what's going on down there what
everybody's tugging at you whenever you
are extended when they give you a pat on
the back in hell they don't give you a
pat on the back they're trying to throw
you off this [ __ ] window they're
trying to clip the ones that can fight
the ones that come back those are the
ones that succeed those are the icons
many legends out there very few icons
powerful that's powerful so this next
one is one of my favorites it says you
trust very few people and those you
trust better never let you down yeah
everyone talks about their inner circle
mm-hmm okay
the greatest inner circle individuals
are so small are so small okay what the
greatest do you know what becomes your
best friend who distance distance
becomes the best friend instance bigger
distance right distance from their
competition okay distance from others
okay distance from their family Wow okay
distance from their friends okay you
have all these individuals that hang out
that hang out together okay we idolize
individuals okay everyone tries to fit
in a group okay you're grown up I want
to be part of this fraternity I want to
hang out with these people I want to
hang out over here
who do you idolize the most the ones
that stand alone the ones that create
distance between you and the competition
and everybody else okay you have all
your friends that they may have all
started off together and what happens is
when you they know they can't keep up
okay you create distance okay you want
them to come with you but they don't
have the ability they don't have the
discipline they don't have the sacrifice
so distance has to become your best
friend in order for you to achieve the
best at what you want to do I know these
are completely different thoughts than
when other people tell what other people
tell you surround yourself with positive
people you know what that means that
means lie to my [ __ ] face so I can
feel good about myself
that's what that means okay you need to
surround yourself with people that tell
you the [ __ ] truth when you're
[ __ ] up they tell you you're [ __ ]
up you made a bad to sit you made a bad
decision now when you say you made a bad
decision now you got to go fix it so now
yes somebody says that to you if this
guy walks away and he's hurting any
sensitive then wouldn't you I you know
what I wait to see if that well first of
all those are the individuals I won't
even work with that there you go oh
that's so you
that's a filtering process for you it's
a filtering I can't handle you pushing
them and giving you pressure this is a
filter phone yeah exactly you know what
and that's why in the category we talk
about three different categories you
talk about your coolers right you talk
about your closures you can talk about
your cleaners now this is where you got
to be very careful of you need all three
in your company your business and your
sports you're in order to succeed if you
only have one group of individuals
you're never gonna make it okay but the
thing you got to understand is you might
have a cooler who's a cooler at work who
comes in does what then their
expectations are low they do what
they're supposed to do they leave during
our hours but they might be a cleaner
and something else
okay okay they might be a cleaner in
raising money for a charity taking care
of their kids whatever it may be so now
when you try it but you see this you see
a different potential in them and you're
trying to say hey you know
man if this person would work just a
little harder they can make so much more
money so and you're thinking in your
mind I want to help this individual I
want to push them and this is where but
that's not what they want to do
that's not where that's not where
they're cleaner status if you struggle
with that by the way okay there you're
hoping the person you like the most
wanted as bad as you write rarely the
case and exactly and that's why you know
we go back to where I said about your
obligation okay your obably people have
different obligations themselves okay
you know we talked about if your can you
be a cleaner in multiple things no you
mean cleaner in one thing
now you can surround your son Jay when
you went to baseball okay I didn't tell
him he could I couldn't he couldn't do
it okay we're gonna we're gonna we're
gonna do whatever we can to make you as
successful as possible now there was a
baseball strike that happened during
that year they wanted him to cross the
line this is you know this is all this
is nothing new this is it's public
information he wouldn't cry he wouldn't
cross a picket line right now was he as
successful as we wanted him to be no but
to take an individual who wanted to try
something and knew the scrutiny that was
going to follow it and the individuals
just to have the mental aptitude to push
himself and continue the same work ethic
that he took in basketball he took in
baseball now you know what they say the
hardest thing in professional sports is
to hit is to hit a baseball I kind of
disagree with that to me it's now to me
the most toughest sport toughest thing
in sports is to be and it's to be an NFL
quarterback because a lot of innovative
baseball players are now hitting buff
275 hitting the 300
how many prized NFL quarterbacks can you
name not that many it's a personal
that's that's a personal opinion okay
that's just mine but when you look at
from you know he hideth to he and the
200 I don't know is I don't know is I
can't remember his average all right but
the pursuit to try to get better every
single every single day regardless of
what everybody else was saying to go
from you know staying in 5-star hotels
when you're with the Chicago Bulls to
stand at hotel
where you can literally just walk up on
the door and having an having a roommate
and a set of flying everywhere
okay having to take a greyhound having
to take a Trailways bus okay and not
asking for special treatment I'm one of
the I'm one of the guys I'm one of the
guys I love that
I'll clearly remember that and I love
that okay that's that's that's amazing
especially the part where you talk about
distance fascinating here's the next one
you don't recognize failure you know
there's more than one way to get what
you want
we're all gonna fail at something
everyone's failed at something okay
but it's only a failure if you decided
to be a failure okay there's just not
one way of getting things done but when
you have an individual and they make
phone calls to sell you your product
okay no is just the start of a different
conversation now if you get no one you
just hang on man I can't do this inning
right okay so failure is what you think
and which it's what you set up in you
know what you set up in your head it's
the individuals that can bounce back for
that okay people are going to people are
going to say no okay they're gonna say
yes okay are you willing to understand
why they said no okay so it doesn't
happen again to the next person it might
not be there it might not be the right
time okay just because you don't win the
championship you don't win the
championship one year okay are you gonna
say I'm a failure okay yeah you know
what you might have not reached the
ultimate goal but next year you retool
you figure out a different way what do I
have to do the one thing that MJ did
every single year and Kobe did this also
is I have to add something new to my
game Wow every single year okay and this
is this is what separates the Great's of
the Great's from everybody else and this
is like I said I'm gonna give you
something new that I've given you some
nuggets already I'm gonna give you some
more they have talent
okay the greats everyone's got talent in
something
okay everyone has talents something but
do you have the intelligence that goes
with that talent okay a lot of people
are talented in a lot of things okay you
got individuals that can run so fast
okay or play in a pickup basketball game
that look unbelievable but now when you
put them in a setting where you have to
have some intelligence where they have
to think about the place or think about
the defense okay think about it have you
ever seen the size of an NFL playbook I
mean it's it's about this thick okay now
those people have to your greatest
quarterbacks they know all the place and
they know all the plays of everybody all
their teammates so you know a lot of
plays aren't like what they do is they
receive or runs out okay and they throw
into a spot they don't throw it to the
person okay the play is hey this is
you're gonna run seven yards yeah you're
gonna break laughs I'm gonna throw a
ball I hate you run seven yards and a
receiver breaks right pause going in the
wrong direction okay so where the talent
has to become the intelligence where the
intelligence has to come the
competitiveness okay
so when you got individuals that are
extremely talented intelligent
intelligent of the competition compare
and they're competitive okay now you
start now you starting to put the pieces
together would you say that's what would
you say Kobe and MJ we're at a whole
different level at that than everybody
else
a whole different level but now when we
talked about failure this is the key
point in this one right here resiliency
resiliency when things go bad when all
the [ __ ] starts to come in okay what
everybody's pulling you in different
directions telling you you can't do this
you can't do that you're you're not this
you had the resiliency to show them okay
you can't win the championship leading
the league in scoring I'm going to show
you
hey you only play one side of the you
only play off the exit fence yep the
Defensive Player of the Year right okay
all right you win it you win the dunk
contests okay everything that says you
can't do it they've done that's
resiliency when you have those four
things and I don't care if it's in
sports it's in business you have to have
those things otherwise our failure is
gonna kick your ass over and over again
because so many people have one of those
four yeah you got a lot of people that
are telling that talented you got a lot
of individuals that are competitive you
got a lot of people who have the
intelligence okay but they do you know
you can have you can have have the in
talent intelligence in something and not
be talented at it so now you have to
find City you have to find something
else so like you know when I was talking
my I had the intelligence in sports
performance and in bat and in basketball
and how the body moves I didn't have the
talent to be a professional bat to be a
professional basketball so you were
self-aware of it exactly okay so all
these things tie in together that's why
when you talk about the 13 everything is
labeled number one because they all I in
together they all tie in together
I like how you explained that so we got
talent intelligence let me see if I've
got this talent intelligence
competitiveness resiliency before
combined together yeah that those are
the individuals he any business
individual listen I just met you mm-hmm
okay never talked to you before okay
you're obviously extremely successful
but you can't be successful you have all
these four traits what I know you're
compared to my father I didn't tell by
just looking at you on that okay
you're extremely talented at what you do
the way I'm not here to kiss you ass I
don't get any I'm not getting I'm not
getting another hit by kissing your ass
on the on the on on this YouTube would
okay if you weren't doing [ __ ] right
I'll be to be the first one to tell you
okay
you have your intelligence you have your
talent you can't be in your line of work
if you're not [ __ ] competitive you
can't be alright that car we wrote in
I'd be a [ __ ] Hyundai okay all right
how many times if you had to adjust in
order for your business to thrive
shitload of times what you might after
just after this interviews over yeah
those four things are in every single
individual that has been successful
wants to be successful if you've missing
one of those pieces you're not you need
to find it because you'll never get to
where you want to be without them
powerful next one you don't celebrate
your achievements because you always
want more it's never enough
now there's an area where greed is good
okay it's listen this isn't about being
I'm not telling you to be this isn't
about being a good person okay you know
like I said earlier everybody wants Pat
everyone wants Pat Pat's on the back
okay you got you got competitors that
step on people's throats mm-hmm and then
you got other [ __ ] competitors that
[ __ ] cut them open okay those are the
individuals that it's never it's never
another simple it's never never enough
okay people always say you know you
gotta love the work okay you gotta love
what you do you don't have to love what
you do you gotta be [ __ ] addicted to
what you do okay you got to be addicted
to winning just like it just like
failure is an addiction
winning is an addiction but guess what
you cannot win you have to trade one
addiction for the other so it's you're
constantly losing you got to trade that
addiction for winning and but here's a
problem when you trade one addiction
guess what then you got to trade another
addiction then you got to trade another
addiction and you got to trade another
one
okay okay you can't you cannot you
cannot work short hours you got to work
long hours you hear people at all here's
one for you I love this one
it [ __ ] drives me crazy okay this one
dries I'm ready okay you got to work
smarter not harder
you got to work smarter and you got to
work [ __ ] harder you gotta [ __ ] do
both Hey you cannot do one okay they
work together you got to work smarter
and you got to work harder okay so
you're telling me okay to work leto to
work smarter but to work less no that's
not gonna happen you mean you're gonna
tell me I'm gonna tell one of my
athletes okay that hey listen you know
what
you only need to practice four hours a
week you'd be like are you [ __ ] crazy
it's not gonna happen okay now you need
to tell me how to be more effective in
what I'm doing if the smarter side okay
that's the smarter side but you're not
gonna tell me I got to work less got it
how obsessive of a worker was MJ and
Colby if I I could think of another word
than obsessive put that on there while
you have to be obsessive you have to be
obsessive you have to be addicted you
have to be disciplined okay the key
there is you everyone else is looking
for other individuals to do stuff for
you stop looking for [ __ ] help from
everybody else okay
it starts and it ends with you your
identity starts and ends with you nobody
nobody else has changed your identity
okay you change your [ __ ] identity
all right and you're the only individual
that can change that can change it back
you know that success oh you've become
successful I bet you get this one all
the time man you've changed you've
changed okay no you haven't changed
everybody else around you has changed
all success is done is magnified who you
really are okay if you're a [ __ ]
prick when you had no money you're a
bigger prick when you have money
okay if you were more if you were
charitable when you didn't have money
you're gonna be more charitable when you
have money okay it's the other
individuals around you okay
and see who didn't see the work that you
put in the time and effort the
dedication the hours that nobody else
saw her the sacrifices missing your kids
events not because you want to nobody
wants to miss them you know nobody wants
to miss any of their kids you know
performances sports games or so forth
okay but it happens it does it does
happen you try to limit it as much as
possible we'll get in this later on then
you know about balance that's one of my
big things you know everyone talks about
balance you know you know how I feel
about balance mixed money the next one
is a favorite this one is one that when
you read the book you're like wait a
minute what's he talking about here you
have a dark side that refuses to be
taught to be good everybody's got a dark
side but do you want to admit it or not
everybody's got one
you see individuals that can to have
that dark side okay that know how to use
it they know how to control it and
everyone talks about dark side is it
being bad it's not about being bad it's
about something that's unique to you
okay it's what fuels you it's what your
desires it's your ego it's your [ __ ]
greed it's what it makes you separate
it's what light import lights your fire
stead of having somebody else light your
fire the dark side keeps your fire lit
it's something that's unique to that
individual to you that pushes you that
pushes you that nobody understands only
you understand it and you see it a lot
of time in in athletes when it gets out
of control
it's you know athletes business
politicians all that other stuff it can
destroy you but the individuals that can
control it
harness it acknowledge it know how to
use it it takes them to a completely
different level masks you know I'd love
to talk about masks and so forth you
know I've in your office one of the unit
your individuals he's got a Batman thing
on then I got a Batman in this and the
Superman okay so we talked about this
you look at an individual you look at
Clark Kent
you look at Bruce Wayne you look at
Batman and you look at Superman
which is a real alter-ego is it Bruce
Wayne or is it Batman
everyone says Batman and Superman is the
alter ego no it's not that's who they
really are okay when they take the mask
off
they become somebody else when they take
the mask or they become somebody else
okay that's who they really are Batman
is who he really is
Superman is who he really is you get
individuals that are so intense at work
okay what happens when they come home
you cannot be that intense at all so
what do you do hey you gotta need a
little time to unwind okay you got to
sit down you become your alter ego when
you go home you are who you are when
you're at work there's things that you
do here in your office from a business
standpoint you would never do in the
house sure you would never do in the
house what I wouldn't want my kids to
see it exactly okay you wouldn't want
your kids to see it all right but are
you really that person or are you a
person you're at work and the person
that you're hired to love the way you
just described this that was fantastic
okay you're that person you are you're
at work people always call me say listen
Rover is the biggest [ __ ] you will
ever meet I don't have a problem with
that I don't have a problem with that
because I'm at a level place where you
you can't think the way I'm thinking you
don't see the things the way I'm the way
I'm seeing it okay now if you call me a
[ __ ] I'm offended because anybody can
be an a at something but there's only
one v [ __ ] the [ __ ]
[Laughter]
you're not intimidated by pressure you
thrive on it everybody can handle
pressure you know what most people
decide not to that's it
most people decide not to be simple it's
not that it's not that complicated and
we're all built to handle pressure yeah
we are okay but what we do we run from
it okay
and what happens be oh I'm stressed you
know what stress is stress is just
pressure you decide that excuse me
stress is just pressure you won't deal
with so if you don't deal with a
pressure situation another pressure
situation comes on and another one comes
on and another one comes on now you're
dealing with stress okay every day you
got a deal with something that you don't
want to do and deal with it first
assuming you have an HR department we
have gym oh you have to okay I hate
[ __ ] HR departments okay I hate them
if a person's not doing their job
wouldn't it be so much easier to say hey
you're not doing your job you're fired
but you choose not to tell them that
because you know what ah you know what
they may be going something at home it's
not a good day something there's all
there's never a good time for the truth
okay but the truth needs to be heard it
needs to be heard if they're not
producing they need to find somebody
else or find some other find some other
because guess what most people struggle
with it it is it is I agree with you on
that I agree with that
okay but the longer you keep that person
cradled in a situation
they're not gonna thrive in it's hurting
yourself and it's hurting those
individuals okay I like that a problem
is only a problem is only a problem when
you decide not to deal with it okay we
always talk about listen when a guy
comes up to me when one of my athlete
are we got a promise no we don't have
problems
we got situations okay
you deal with a situation that never
becomes a problem if you don't deal with
a situation then it becomes a problem so
deal with it while it's a situation when
it gets to be a problem now you now
you're gonna have issues I like it
five more when everyone is hitting the
where everyone is hitting that in case
them an emergency button they are
looking for you you have individuals
that when [ __ ] hits the fan everybody
panics okay you know yeah and this is a
great example about this one okay I'm a
beast Oh everyone how many times you
hear that man I'm a beast a beast you
know what you're only a beast until it's
time to do beastly things then you find
out who the [ __ ] Beast really is when
there's a case of an emergency
that's the individual those are your
Navy SEALs those are your individuals
that are gonna get everybody out into a
situation they're not gonna they're not
gonna panic they're gonna see what's
going on they're gonna figure it out
they're gonna see that situation they're
gonna make sure that best outcome
possible is going to happen with the
minimum amount minimal amount of damage
and there's very few people that can do
that Tom Brady after the after the
halftime game or when he completed that
pass and they scored the field goal like
when he went into the locker room you
know he told his teammates we gonna win
this [ __ ] game you don't win this
game in cases of emergency they're all
looking at once he told his teammates
that they're like oh yeah my man's got
us what they do they came back and won
the game like but it takes a special
individual and this is like I said where
you talk about the 13 they gotta all be
tied in together they got to all be tied
in together one is more important oh
yeah the one it's not more important and
here's the key about you talk about the
emergency button the emergency buttons
are the individuals okay they don't
count the days they make the day's count
you get all the end of the man
eight more days of vacation you've
already checked out yeah okay the
individuals your in case of emergency
buttons thinking about man I got eight
days I got to get [ __ ] done no way I
gotta have make [ __ ] because when I
leave this or when I leave this office
and I'm gone for two weeks or whatever
it is okay in case something happens
it's already I've already seen it I've
already dealt with it
I've already told somebody else how to
handle it so and the deal to make sure
the situation can be handled under any
circumstances those are the individuals
that are in case of your emergency
there's not that many of them everybody
thinks they are if everybody thinks or
you get the individual that if you're in
a room and there's a fire how many
people just start scrambling and panic
and you got to but I calm down this is
where the exits are that's how we gonna
get it broken you go through here
they've already evaluated this situation
and they've thought about every single
possible scenario positive and negative
that can go wrong okay and every
scenario there's somebody like that
there's always somebody there's all and
you know what sometimes you don't even
know who that person is right until
that's until they have to rise up to
that left till they have to rise up to
Detroit circumstances bring extreme
competitive confidence out of an
individual you want to see how tough for
an individual is put them under a
pressure situation see how they're gonna
deliver see how they're gonna do it
everybody you know what everybody wants
to sit in your seat everybody wants to
everyone wants to be the head coach okay
everyone wants to be the boss until they
got to sit in that first seat and find
out what's actually the decisions that
you have to make how many people are
relying on you every little action that
you do every little mistake everything
positive then it begins to be too much
you get an individual in sports they get
traded from team to team because they
want to be the man until it's time to be
the man and I oh wait a minute
too much rushing yeah I mean let me sit
here I don't want the pressure I don't
want to be the in-case-of-emergency but
I want to be the third or fourth guy on
the team and I'm good and I'm good with
that you don't compete with anyone you
find your opponent's weakness and you
attack everyone's got a weakness in
businesses what do you look for you look
for you look for
body else's weakness and you like it
either we're gonna buy them out okay or
this is what we're stronger at and we're
going after it
people have gotten too soft these days
they've gotten too soft okay that's why
people meet my man man you're always so
angry no I'm not angry okay this isn't
that nothing you haven't seen me angry
okay this has got nothing to do with
anger I'm just telling you the truth
all right that's what I'm telling you
okay it's too much people
there's too much hugging and too much
high-fives and all that [ __ ] going on
when you haven't earned it
okay you go to these seminars you go to
the hey you turn around give the person
next to you a pat on the back give him a
high-five get mohawk
when I come from you got to earn your
[ __ ] high fives
okay you got to earn your accolades you
got to earn your hug but this isn't
about participation trophies you don't
get you don't get rewarded for
participating you don't get rewarded for
participating in life
I got passionate I got an inner Drive
you got a person that you come into your
office have you ever given anybody a
raise because the results sunk but they
got great passionate in their Drive
oh they passionate in the drive has to
be followed by an action you have to
have an action that follows it and
that's the hardest part people don't
want to have that action everyone talks
about man
they got all these dreams dancing in
their head I want to do this I want to
do this I want to do guess what dreams
want to live just like everybody else
and if you don't bring them to life
somebody else will they're gonna jump
from your head right into somebody
else's head and that person is gonna
bring those dreams to life and you're
gonna be sitting there back thinking man
I could have I should have I've would
have all right you had your chance you
got to deliver you got to have action
you got to deliver I like that three
more left we got here you make decisions
not suggestions you know the answer
while everyone everyone else is asking
questions people were reason they don't
want to make decisions because then you
got to answer the hard question
it's easy to make a suggestion because
that way you can also I was just a
suggestion or you can put it on somebody
else but when it's a decision you gotta
answer the hard questions you have to
answer the hard questions okay the thing
about when you talk about decisions and
so forth the one thing I tell people is
everyone else a and we got to smooth
things out we got to do this listen I'll
tell you one thing
there is nothing smooth about me not the
way I walk not the way I talk that's the
way I handle my athletes okay there's
nothing smooth about the way I do things
okay I'm not that so I'm not that soft
side of the sponge on that other side of
the sponge that you you know when you
got to scrape the dirt off of it and you
got to get the grease out that's what
that's what I do those are those
individuals you had everyone I want to
set the world on fire well guess what
you send the world on fire you better
learn how to [ __ ] put that fire out
you better learn how to put that fire
out you don't have to love the work but
you're addicted to the results so we
talked about this a little bit earlier
well everyone talks about man you name
one individual we have quite a few
individuals in this room right now
they were you and I are talking you're
gonna sit here and tell me there's that
you love everything about your job every
single bit of it no that's [ __ ] you
don't love everything about your job
there's certain things you just just
people love the long hours no people
want to getting up the phone calls do I
like having to watch a game at 3 o'clock
in the morning but know I have to be
prepared but I'm addicted to the result
I'm addicted to the result okay and when
you're addicted to the result you rather
have you need individuals that are
around you okay that they are there to
educate you not entertain you and you
see the biggest fall of an athlete is
when they surround themselves with
individuals that entertain them and
those are you yes people instead of
individuals
that educate that educates you surround
yourself with people that are going to
educate educate you that's what I do to
my athletes that's what the athletes do
to me you know when I've crossed over in
a different sports I've had to learn the
nuances of you know what a quarterback
has to go through what a you know
baseball right you know right-field or a
hitter
okay those individuals I don't want them
to entertain me with jokes and you know
their entourage and so forth okay the
majority of my guys don't have entourage
is because they keep their inner circle
small alright I want them to educate me
just like I'm educating that powerful
powerful and last but not least you'd
rather be feared than like it's not a
popularity contest when you're
individuals get on the phone okay what's
their job to sell mm-hmm
the job isn't to make friends but you
make make some friends along the way but
it's your job okay to get those results
the competitors are feared they are
feared okay and you know how they handle
how they handle fear right you work out
mm-hmm right okay how do you make your
muscles grow through resistance right
sure you lift weights you want them to
grow bigger you add more resistance all
right it's the same thing in business
it's the same thing in life it's the
same thing from a mental standpoint you
have to add resistance do you think
people crack when there's too much
resistance and you kind of start
learning about yourself and the people
around you right but that's again like
you if you add too much weight you're
not gonna be able to let you're not
gonna let you're gonna hurt yourself if
this is your next but you need to
continue to address you need to continue
to add resistance just like you that's
how your brain grows you know when
people run from when they run from
pressure and so forth okay that that
your brain needs that pressure it's
thrives off of it that's how it grows
that's how it wants to be rebooted you
know you talk about individuals you get
a you get an update on your phone on a
regular basis right you get a new app
you get this you get a new phone you
move up to our iPhone 7 iPhone 8
wherever the hell they're at the
galaxy's all these different things okay
and you do this you change them when's
the last time you [ __ ] rebooted this
when's the last time this got a joke
what's the last time this got a but you
know a charge it need it needs to be
challenged it needs to be worked with
okay and those are the individuals that
you you're fearful of because they're
never satisfied they always want more
they're gonna educate themselves and
gonna become better those are the
individuals that are fear you go into a
company if you're selling a policy and
you're the best at what you do and
somebody else is selling a policy and
they walk into an office and they see
you sitting outside in that office after
they made that presentation they should
could be coming out of there and said oh
[ __ ] we got no chance they got a better
product the person's gonna know the
product better they offer better service
they got better customer individuals
they got they got everything that's what
I'm talking about that's what I'm
talking about fear you'd rather be
feared than light so here's here's close
we get to the closings I'm really
curious about talking about the program
that you have as well that people can
participate and then learn more about
the team why is it worth it I mean you
know somebody could be watching this
ain't Oman you want me to go through
this pain you want me to go through
resistance you want me to go through
this young me to work hard why is it
worth it I mean it's the part about
being worth the price you're gonna pay
is that an individual thing or can
somebody who's sit and be inspired to
say listen I got it it is worth I'm
gonna give everything I got to this one
thing when he's saying mastery I'm gonna
give everything I got that is one thing
to master but why is it worth it because
the results are so [ __ ] good it feels
so [ __ ] good when you can get there
it really does then people always fall
just a little short before just right
before they get there okay and what
we're trying to do is
than what the relentless system does
it's a mindset before you have an
exceptional skill set okay you have to
have the right mindset you have to have
a great mindset so when you're sitting
there you're trying to sell your product
you're making phone calls you're giving
a lecture whatever it may be you're
driving a bus your doctor whatever it
may be the stronger your mindset is the
greater your skill set is going to be
it's not the it's not the other way
around when you drop mine fit strong
grrrrrr this skill set okay
Michael and Kobe weren't the greatest
athletes that I've ever worked with okay
they were great athletes they weren't
the greatest okay but their mindset is
what separates those individuals Tom
Brady was he was drafted a hundred and
ninety-ninth okay he's a six round pick
okay so that's gonna tell you right now
from an athletic standpoint he wasn't
the most athletic okay but from a
mindset standpoint okay he's a [ __ ]
killer he is a killer I mean you could
see the other thing was shivering yes
okay you know everyone talks about this
oh you know the other team choked no
they didn't choke
okay the Patriots made them choke so
huge there's a huge difference yeah huge
huge difference so so look I mean you
know I have to ask you this because I
have friends who are diehard LeBron guys
LeBron's the modern-day you know give
them you know these the main face right
now Durant wanted obviously last year
Curry's got some stuff going on so
there's a part in the book where you
talk about that I hate I read the hard
but harsher so would you consider a
LeBron James a cleaner what it when we
originally wrote the hardcover we said
no okay even though we had won
championships in Miami okay but the
claim was a cleaner Dwayne and Pat Riley
were the cleaners on those on that on
those teams Dwayne and Ron yes okay
they're the ones that were the Pat are
they
the cleaners on that team LeBron from a
skillset standpoint you know
unbelievable talent unbelievable talent
okay can do every facet on the on the
basket on the basketball court but he
didn't know how to win he knew how to
compete he didn't know how to win okay
when he came down to Miami okay they
showed him how to win mm-hmm he knew how
to compete they showed him how they
showed him how to win he won the chitti
won the championships not when he went
back to Cleveland and won the
championship down there I did move him
to clean her status to be able to go
back into your hometown home city with
all that Pratt with all that pressure
with a team that wasn't really that that
good regardless of the circumstances of
the of the other teams you know the
victim I told draymond Green if he
didn't get suspended they would have won
while you know you can go back and say
well when they played him before if
Kyrie Irving didn't go down who knows
what the results don't forget about if
if could all that our stuff okay to go
down and do what he did I did put him on
I did put him up the cleaner I did put
him up to cleaner status but the problem
with being and reaching cleaner status
is you got to be able to do it over and
over again okay
he played at a very high level but he
wasn't able to elevate his teammates to
play at that high level they played as
well as they could the year before you
know you look at Iman Shumpert you look
at Channing Frye you look at Tristan
Thompson they didn't even come close to
that level that they played at two years
ago alright now your job as a leader is
to hold those individuals accountable
this is the difference again when you
talk about friendship feared and being
light okay you put him in the category
of LeBron is not
feared like he should boy when he steps
on the phone the other guy's not afraid
like there being energy there there's
that little factor that he's missing now
can it be taught and can it be changed
yes he can't few years left there's got
nothing much he doesn't have money he
doesn't have much time okay but that's
that's that's the difference okay when
MJ stepped out on the court okay
it even use a different example you know
we talked about I'm Joe talk about Larry
Bird Larry Bird was known as one of the
biggest trash talkers out there okay you
know why those individuals talk trash
not only to get into the opponent's head
but to psych themselves up because now
if they say this is what I'm gonna do
they have to elevate their game they
have to bat they have to back it up they
have to back it up so the trash talking
isn't only one-sided it's both it's both
sides fine so when you go out there you
can't be worried about what this is not
about friendship you're not out on the
court to make you're not out in the
competitiveness to make friends you can
afterwards you want to go out hanging
out hang a drink so we can do that we
can do that but when it comes to winning
okay LeBron is a step on your throat God
he's not a cut yourthroat guy so your
number one draft pick of all the time if
you have to start a team first pick is
who MJ
hyojong hands down second team Olajuwon
third
Kobe Bryant for Team Elijah on a second
huh Isiah Thomas five
this is that that that's that so we got
Isaiah we got MJ or Kobe Kobe no you
haven't said Bernie said akim akim so I
got Isaiah's my point MJ's mine too
Larry Larry
that's a tough it's a tough but you know
what listen you got Kevin Durant you got
Kevin Durant you got Kevin Durant out
there yeah I'm a huge Scottie Pippen fan
of client for many many years
all right you know when you talk about
winners you know you got to talk about
Magic Johnson you know so there's a
there's no there's no perfect there's no
perfect fit but what I'm looking at is
people talk about the individuals that I
picked it doesn't matter what era they
played in how the game was rafting how
the rules have changed they would adapt
adjust and overcome it didn't make it
doesn't it doesn't matter it doesn't
matter whatever it is whatever to the
day whatever Airness so Tim I can look
question for you so anybody that spends
a lot of time with you obviously they're
going to be thinking about in a
different way they're gonna be preparing
in a different way their mindsets gonna
change but most people can't spend 80
grand 100 grand or whatever the amount
is to be able to have somebody like you
work with them directly you you told me
that you now have a program all these
years you haven't done anything like
this everyday you just launched last
week were last week anybody around the
world can get one-on-one time in a
website they can go literally learn for
you 50 different videos it's called the
relentless system okay and it's me
talking to you the way I talk to my
athletes but not only from what I've
learned what I've learned from these
individuals are the thing that I got a
chance to do being blessed to work with
the greatest of the Great's is they hung
out with the greats
okay so I got a chance
to see MJ Scottie
Kobe sit down and talk to a Wayne
Gretzky talk to a John Elway talked with
Muhammad Ali okay
Floyd Mayweather Roger Federer okay to
see all these and just for them to sit
there and just listen to no cameras no
nothing just sit there talk ask about
that you know the Derek Jeter's about
what you know what competition means to
them what do they do to get to that next
level and this wasn't just a one-time
thing this was like you know people call
these these they have these things call
the masterminds what do you think that
was going on in there you talk about the
ultimate cleaners and your competitors
in there and I'm just sitting there like
a little fly on the wall that never left
and I'm just absorbing all this
information and I'm that's the
information I'm giving you in this
system is what the best of the best in
their competitive nature's how they
think and not only as it relates to
sports as it relates to anything you do
whether it's whether it's business
whether it's sales whether it's raising
your kids it's being able to identify
these traits and what it takes to be
exceptional and improve at what what
you're trying to do because there's
always a next level all right there's
over 50 plus programs
all right normally the program sells 4.1
thousand two hundred ninety seven
dollars back okay but because of this
are my relationship with you and we're
gonna continue to do business for your
viewers your listeners I'm giving them
40% off 40% off the 1297 also 1297
50-plus videos you can watch it on your
eye you can watch it all of your your
phone your tablet your computers you can
take it with you it's like having me
work it's like having me in your [ __ ]
bedroom stuck to your ass wherever you
want me to be pretty I think I'm I'm
there okay I'm there all right but what
you have to do in order to get that
discount in order to get that discount
Oh
you have to text the word cleaner CL EA
n er to 96,000 if you text cleaner to
96,000 you get that discount cleaner to
96,000 yes and the formation center and
with the 40% discount 40% dis i nap and
go for that and I'm telling you you
won't be disappointed okay if you
enjoyed the way I talked and the lessons
and the stuff I gave you today and I
told you it's gonna be different all
right
like I said this isn't about high-fives
this isn't about hugs this is not a
sugar high that wears off okay you want
to know what the ultimate competitors do
okay how they think how they act and why
they're so successful and this is
remember successes you measure what
success is it's for some individuals
it's money okay for other individuals it
could be happiness
it could be charitable things it could
be whatever the definition of success is
something you decide of what it is for
you to be alright this will help you get
there here's what I can tell you
Harrison we were talking about Harrison
those Steelers a linebacker what's James
Harrison right I mean just 95 I think
his numbers 95 is it 95 I think it's 95
he did an interview last week or was the
last week yeah he's been doing quite a
bit yeah and he they asked him they said
so what do you spend every year on what
do you spend every year on would he call
it on mother's body on your body he says
$375,000 per year yeah so how can you
plan you're so old you know you you're
not the typical 26 year old but here's
thing he's just not playing he's playing
at a very high level in position he gets
it and he can last this long the time
the reason why I'm telling that story
here is because I'm a byproduct of
having invested on a lot of different
programs that shaped my mindset and if
there's one area I was cheap when it
came to close early my career was cheap
when it came down to cars I was a big
cash saver I was never cheap when it
came down to putting money into how I
can think from somebody that has a
proven track record
everybody watching this admires em Jake
15 years he mentored MJ for his
conditioning personal training there's a
reason for that there's something that
can be learned there so my encouragement
will be one more time cleaner text
cleaner to the number 96 thousand text
cleaner to the number 96 thousand to get
more information about what our friend
here Tim Grover is gone and by the way
if you haven't read the book relentless
100 percent you got to get yourself and
everybody else reading the book
relentless it's a must read it's one of
those books where I read every erase
everyone's got to read this book so I
got to give this ring back yeah but hold
on you give me that one back now I'm
gonna give you this one kid me here
that's a Lakers championship ring 2009
is this the Celtics won yeah you want to
know what's the craziest thing about
this I was at this game that's unfair
this is your ring yeah
un-freakin'-believable man he's being
polite
I'm [ __ ] like holy [ __ ] I told you I
had a surprise I'm a freaking believable
man that's sick and it's got what it's
got Grover on the seconds you were you
were working with Kobe the lab at this
time mm-hmm
so you got went from bulls and you got
oh I got sick I got six [ __ ] all on
let's get this straight I got six from
Chicago one from nah okay I got six from
Chicago okay
please correct me I'm gonna cry when I'm
a cracker I'm gonna correct you right
now okay I got six from Chicago got four
from LA they got three from Miami six
413 yeah listen man this is pretty wild
you wouldn't want to do a fist bump with
this one you can get her to do with this
this is insane here well brother
appreciate you coming up oh my pleasure
such a good time lunch this meeting cure
just truly had a very good time and guys
I'm just telling you if you haven't yet
gone and done the 96,000
cleaners texting it to 96,000 go do it
there's a lot to be learned from
man that work directly with MJ for 15
years this isn't some social media guru
that's telling you how to go out and do
Instagram this is a man that worked with
a guy who owns a sports team who's the
greatest basketball player of all time
highly recommend you go out and get this
program that ten growers offering they
just launched the last week again thanks
again for coming my pleasure thank you
thank you thank you
[Music]